[Music]
now the prime minister has had something
else on his mind this week it's his
twice cancelled
trip to india covet levels there are
getting pretty serious
registered the biggest spike in the
world recently
and he figured perhaps understandably
now is not the best time for
a trip but how much of this is down to
the new variant strain of covet
that's been discovered over there i'm
joined by somebody who can distill the
facts from the panic
dr jeffrey barrett directs the covet 19
genomics initiative
at the welcome sangha institute in
cambridge and he joins me now dr barrett
welcome to spectator
tv now we've heard a lot about the
indian
variants but what do we know about it
and to what extent
is it overwhelming india in the same way
that the kent variants
changed the narrative here in britain
and on the continent
yeah the short answer is i don't think
we know yet
um there is some evidence that this new
variant
dubbed b1617 has been growing in
frequency
in india at the same time as the recent
tragic surge
but that can sometimes happen uh by
coincidence and it doesn't necessarily
prove on its own
that the new variant is in fact driving
that surge
the way we tried to unpick that problem
in the case of the kent variant back in
december last year
was we could watch because we do quite a
lot of what we call genomic surveillance
in the uk where we sequence the genome
of the virus to really carefully track
each variant from place to place and
what we saw there was that every time
the
b117 or kent variant would arrive in a
new place in the uk
it would very rapidly completely take
over and we've seen the same thing
happen in other countries
in the month since then so that takes
quite a lot of data to build a
sort of very compelling picture and i
think right now we actually just don't
have enough information about this new
b1617 variant
right how difficult is it to track
because the kent variant
that was detectable by an s gene dropout
which you can pick up through a standard
pcr test is the indian variant one that
you would need more advanced
methods to detect and is that why we're
such a question mark about its
prevalence
that's exactly right so the kent variant
had a kind of coincidental
useful property and that one of its
mutations made it as you said trackable
by
a certain signal in the pcr test that we
use very widely
and that means we could see it in kind
of real time and also
in very large numbers of tests conducted
in the uk
the b1617 variant in india doesn't have
that property one needs to
read the complete genome of the virus in
every sample to be certain
whether it's present or not and at the
moment there's
growing but relatively small amount of
genome sequencing in india so they've
had
over four million cases in this current
wave
but only published about a thousand
sequences it's a tiny proportion and
it can be very difficult to know if that
proportion that have been sequenced are
representative of the huge number of
cases that are
being transmitted and if they aren't
then that means you can't sort of
make the leap that the exact proportion
we see in the sequence data represents
how much is out there in the country as
a whole all right
now there's been a lot said about how
this is a double mutant strain which
sounds
pretty terrifying is it yeah i think
that's really overblown
um so all of these variants of concern
that we've been looking at the kent one
uh the the b1351 from south africa the
one that was first seen in brazil
these all have a number of mutations so
the virus has about 30 000 letters in
its genome
and usually these variants that seem
concerning have
10 or 20 mutations or differences
from the ancestral version the same is
true of
of the indian variant it has i forgot
about a dozen i think
two of which are potentially concerning
and those two are why someone coined it
the double mutant
one of them was previously seen in a
variant in california
i'd actually say those two mutations
that have grabbed headlines are not
in the top tier of biologically scariest
mutations compared for example to some
of the ones in the
kent or south african variants and for
that reason i think we don't know
whether it's very difficult to predict
this virus and whether there might be
some aspect of its biology we don't
understand
but i don't think there's any need to
panic right now i don't think there's
any clear evidence for example
that these mutations would make vaccines
less effective against this variant
how many mutations are there of covert
that we know or how many can we estimate
but there are so far
so there are many tens of thousands of
mutations because these things happen
sort of all the time in the virus in all
the transmissions that are happening
around the world
so tens of thousands of mutations and
but why should it be that when we see
one from kent one from south africa one
from mexico
that we talk as if the very mutation is
reason to worry about something going on
if there are tens of thousands of
mutations anyway
well i think that's a good point and and
um almost all of the mutations we see
do basically nothing to the virus's
biological properties and are not
interesting except
they can be used as a kind of bar code
to track the virus
the reason that we do get somewhat
excited about
the indian variant in the kent one and
so forth is that some of those mutations
have properties that make them perhaps
more worrying so for example
when they appear in the spike protein of
the virus that's the
kind of most important bit the virus
uses to bind to human cells
that is likely more concerning
more recently there have been a number
of laboratory experiments where specific
mutations
have been tested in viruses and dishes
to show that for example they can bind
more tightly to human cells and infect
better or that possibly they can
evade certain antibodies that our immune
systems produce so i think
we're getting better at having these
predictors of which mutations are a bit
worrying
and which ones are probably benign and
meanwhile we can keep account of them
can't we i mean the
the variant's been here for several
months now since february and right now
i think there's only something like 100
cases being detected so can we deter
can we infer from that that the indian
variant whether it's more dangerous or
not
is certainly not growing in the way that
the kent variant has pretty much taken
over the coveted story
in continental europe i think that's
likely the case
it's difficult to make a direct
comparison because of course in the last
few months the country has been under a
tight lockdown and that seems to be
driving down the numbers of all variants
of the virus which is very good news
um but one thing that's becoming clear
is that of the hundred or so
observations so far
almost all of them i think are either
from people who recently traveled from
india or the contacts
of of those travelers and that means
that in some sense the
early warning system is working we're
detecting that now we know there's a lot
of cases in india
we know a lot of people test positive
when they travel from there
and a reasonable fraction of them have
this b1617 but
it doesn't seem yet to be transmitting
onward in the community generally and i
think that's a very
good sign so far and obviously something
we have to watch very carefully going
forward
now i imagine well can you ever see a
time where
we would not be worried about a covered
mutation
it's argued that as the as the virus
enters its
final years we can anything expect more
more dangerous um
mutations as it seeks to evolve and
dodge the vaccines
but i'm thinking that right now we're
closing our borders if we're taking
very strong quarantine regulations
because we're worried about the
potential
mutation for the virus of where there
are tens of thousands of mutations
i can't quite see the process where this
ends and where we would not
be worried from what you're saying kobud
will keep mutating for the rest of his
life on this planet
and there is i can't quite see at what
point we start stop worrying
about mutations well i think um
in some sense that's right we're
entering a kind of new phase of the
pandemic where
there are variants around the world and
we watch carefully and
and are most interested in knowing if
any of those variants are less well
neutralized by vaccines and you know we
i think we don't know yet and that's the
reason for concern that being said i
think it really emphasizes
a fundamental point that a number of
people from the who and others have made
which is
nowhere in the world is really safe
until everywhere is safe
it is not sensible to think that if the
uk successfully finishes vaccinating its
entire population
but there are hundreds of thousands of
cases per day in india
that the pandemic is somehow over for us
travel restrictions are one way to try
to
limit that that sort of import and
onward transmission
in that situation obviously australia
and new zealand for example have been
doing that for months already
but i don't think anybody wants to live
in a world where we permanently have
such strict travel restrictions
and i think that's why efforts to more
equitably distribute vaccines around the
whole world are so very important
i'm sure but this is what a lot of
people can't quite understand
if we end up with herd immunity in this
country the government thinks we're
going to get there
by october some and think we'll get
there earlier
but say if we hit there at one point
isn't the whole purpose there
that any variant of of kovitz any one of
the tens of thousands that we've spoken
about
ought not to trouble us simply because
it wouldn't be able to spread because it
wouldn't
find enough people to spread to i can't
quite work out why
if we do hit herd immunity which is the
government's strategy perhaps an
undeclared strategy but if we hit her
immunity through vaccination
why would we then be worried about
people bringing covert into britain
if we're not aware of any mutant strain
which dodges the vaccine or causes
re-infection
well exactly that is the x factor which
is there are no variants
yet proven to dodge vaccines or cause
reinfection but there are some
for which there is reasonable concern or
worry that they might be better able to
um reinfect individuals who have been
vaccinated and that's the
so that's i think hopefully not a very
likely outcome that there will be
fundamentally variants that will be able
to evade the vaccines at a very
substantial level but obviously the
consequence of that is so
enormous that i think governments are
taking precautionary steps to say
we get to hurt immunity we try to gather
as much data as possible to understand
if these
new variants pose a real threat to that
herd immunity or if they
there is for example a possibility that
some of these variants might
um create some infections but they'll be
relatively mild
possibly unlikely to transmit on
onwardly and possib and very unlikely to
become severe disease or death and that
might be something that
society can learn to live with so i
think that's the
question is which of those possible
scenarios is likely to play out
an unlikely but very bad one where we'd
have another wave of a new variant of
the virus
a perhaps also unlikely but very rosy
one where the vaccines work perfectly
against every variant of the virus
or something in between where we have to
sort of adjust our lifestyle
in response to exactly whether there are
other variants
and how much they might not be as as
neutralized by the vaccines
at what points can we declare that we're
no longer worried for example
about the south african variant that was
found in some laboratory tests science
and some
real world tests to be le and better at
getting through the astra
vaccine for example and then there's
some studies in israel recently looking
at people who had been infected despite
having been vaccinated
and they found far greater prevalence of
south africa south africa variant
than they had thought but still if you
look at south africa itself their cases
are down something like 98
from the peak so i'm not quite sure at
what stage we think
okay we've seen a couple of concerning
studies but realistically it's not that
much
of a threat it's difficult to declare
with any confidence
that whatever new variant it is be
indian south african brazilian
is no longer a threat you're going to
get concerning studies that are
always going to aren't they not give us
pause for concern i just can't quite see
when this cycle would end
well i think we will get more
informative data the
one of the studies that you alluded to
in israel is informative i think in that
they did see
a larger proportion of um
of infections after double-dose
vaccination of the south african variant
but the total number if i remember
rightly was something like eight yeah so
it's
perhaps this is this is where i was
going but it can perhaps get through a
bit better
but it's not as if israel is
experiencing
a um a wave right now of south africa
very
getting through the vaccine so i think
that's take us a good
point of confidence i think you'll see
again perhaps some data from
the eastern part of france and
luxembourg and europe have a reasonable
amount of b1351 the south african
variant
they're also vaccinating quite quickly
so we should get data there
and we'll also be looking very carefully
in the uk here
we have very low levels of of the south
african variant in the community
um and the government is trying hard to
get that to zero with things like the
surge testing in south london we saw a
week or so ago
but i think what we'll do in the next
month or so as
restrictions are lifted we sequence a
very large fraction more than half now
of all the the new
positive cases in the countries we know
how many cases of these variants there
are
and we'll be able to ask questions like
are we seeing more cases of south africa
now that we're getting close to herd
immunity
are they enriched in the vaccines
compared to other lineages of the virus
and i think you're right that hopefully
there will be
a kind of drum beat of reassuring
stories that will mean we don't have to
be quite as
petrified of these variants as we
perhaps have been
of course we're talking about vaccines
all the time but a variant which causes
reinfection is as much
of a risk now it's uh more than a year
since the virus kicked off
how many countries have it been where
reinfections have been
um a feature of the pandemic i was
trying to have a look at
reinfection numbers and they're pretty
hard to find i think there's a dutch
company which tries to list them and
it's got fewer than 150 documented
reinfections worldwide that struck me as
a
very low number for a virus where
they've been tens of millions of
infections i don't know if your
institute has been looking at this in
any greater detail
so so we haven't in particular but we
have been contributing data to it to i
think an important effort to look at
this it turns out to be
just very hard to prove reinfection um
sometimes people for example
shed virus for months after they've been
infected at a very low level and it can
look like another infection but really
it's just
some kind of unusual tale of their first
one so
there have been studies set up to try to
find these things there's one called
siren in the uk which is a study of
healthcare workers where you can imagine
is a good place to look because one it's
much easier to keep careful records and
do things like
sequence the genome of every infection
to know conclusively this is a different
variant than the person got
you know back in october of last year or
whatever and the other thing is of
course healthcare workers are
exposed more often to the virus than
most of us are
so there are efforts to document these
numbers it's still as you say
these these clear-cut cases are are
small numbers i suspect there are more
uh in the community there's an
interesting piece of technique you can
say a bit about what this siren study
has found if you say but that is
britain's number one reinfection study
right now is siren
what's a siren found about reinfection
levels how many reinfections has it
found
um well i think what it's found is uh
that
previous infection offers as we would
expect very substantial i think it's
something like 85
reduced risk of getting infected again
and i don't think they found
as yet any association between secondary
infection
and um which variant is uh
you're exposed to the second time i
suspect that's going to take a bit more
time because
the the sort of types of variants that
one has been exposed to in the uk has
been shifting over the period in which
the study's been running so
you know back last fall it was one
particular mix that swept through being
ken to the point where today
99.9 of new infections are the kent
variant so it's kind of
quite um difficult to tell them apart
i think there's also some interesting
data from the
ons office for national statistics and
oxford university study which looks at
the general population survey every week
and one thing they've found is pretty
consistently
there's a way the pcr test measures
approximately how much virus is in the
sample that you
take and that second infections tend to
have less virus than first infections
and i think that
kind of makes sense so that even
individuals who do get a second
infection
probably get a more mild infection and
they also might be
less aware that they even are infected
the second time around if they don't
have strong symptoms
and that might also be a factor for why
so far it's been very hard to pin down
numbers
of re-infections in the community
because the second time around it might
be
less likely that you notice and and
it's funny when you pick up the papers
abroad people talk about the british
variant as if it's which obviously is a
major problem for them but
i'm wondering what do you think the
chances are that the british variant
actually
started in britain we do more genome
sequencing than any other country in the
world i think
and it's fair to say isn't it simply
more likely that we found it first but
it probably started somewhere else
well i think that was certainly a
possibility when we first observed it
for exactly the reason you say we had a
very
powerful microscope to look at these
things and so when we found it it
was hard to tell the difference between
whether it had originated in britain or
somewhere else
i i'm increasingly i'm not sure but
increasingly confident it probably did
originate in the uk
and the reason for that is um it seems
to transmit
so quickly that if it had risen
somewhere else
some substantial amount of time before
it in the uk there would have been a
very bad wave there
and in the wake of the discovery of the
british and south africa and other
variants
many many countries are now doing
sequencing and we haven't yet seen a
country turn up where we can look back
and say aha
they probably had a very bad way if it
was caused by this instead we usually
see it kind of
starting in other countries on a lag of
months
from when it began in the southeast of
england so again
no way to be totally certain but i think
it is
um reasonably likely that it began in
either
the southeast somewhere in kent or
possibly in the east of london which is
where we saw the very earliest sequences
in the uk
okay but so far i imagine no virus has
ever been scrutinized with as much
expertise as the coronavirus has
um we're not seeing any significant
number of re-infections they seem to be
absolutely tiny and we're not seeing any
of the tens of thousands of variants of
dog to the vaccine
might it be fair to say that that's two
pieces of reasonably good news
i think it probably is i mean i think we
can't be too certain yet
that none of these variants are are
going to be
less well neutralized by the vaccines um
you know i don't think we have seen
i think one way to put it would be we
have certainly not yet seen a
really bad piece of news about a
particular variant and vaccine efficacy
in real world data
and as you kind of said before the
longer that time goes by
and there are variants out there in
countries where there's a lot of
vaccines
the more and more that kind of lack of
bad news becomes good news
dr jeffrey barrett thanks very much for
joining us on spectator tv
[Music]
you